[Musique]
qui était l'
un des écosystèmes les plus intéressants
du monde avant les années 60,
la zone est désormais pour un tiers
une zone désertique où bien sûr
la biodiversité n'existe plus et
la plupart des espèces  ont disparu
[Musique]
l'eau des deux rivières
a été prélevée
lors de travaux d'ingénierie générale en construisant
des fuites en construisant des canaux qui, bien sûr,
ont aussi modifié la morphologie de la zone
[Musique]
quand il y a une sorte de
pompage qui est si extrême que le niveau
du  le lac a diminué de 17
[Musique]
mètres
[Musique] [
Musique]
aussi des oiseaux et de nombreuses autres espèces d'
animaux
en raison de l'impersonnalisation du
lac mais pas seulement l'augmentation
du désert a créé
les tempêtes de soleil, celles-ci créent bien sûr
un climat et une situation
cela ne permet pas aux espèces
vivant dans la région de continuer à
survivre
[Musique] [
Musique]
il y avait une augmentation de la pauvreté en raison
du manque d'accès à l'eau et de la sécurité de l'eau, c'était
un désastre économique
[Musique]
nous savons que  les pesticides et les engrais
s'infiltrent dans le sous-sol
puis atteignent les aquifères les
ressources en eaux souterraines
et bien sûr l'eau potable proviennent principalement
des richesses qui pompent
dans ces aquifères
[Musique]
au kazakhstan le niveau des lacs a
augmenté
et certains des  les espèces sont de retour
mais en même temps ces barrages
ne permettent pas à l'écoulement de l'eau
d'atteindre la partie sud du rlc
[Musique]
les deux rivières la sirdaria et la
rivière amudaria
qui prennent leur source de l'
hindukushi et de la pamira
avant  pour atteindre l'Ouzbékistan et le
Kazakhstan,
ils passent par l'Afghanistan, le Kirghizistan
et le Tadjikistan, le problème est bien plus
que la
gestion de l'eau par l'Ouzbékistan et le Kazakhstan,
il s'agit en réalité d'une coordination et d'une
coopération régionales pour la gestion
des eaux transfrontalières de la région
sans une véritable gestion
et gouvernance durable
de  les ressources en eau et en particulier la
protection des glaciers en regardant
l'impact du changement climatique il n'y
aura certainement pas beaucoup d'avenir pour le rlc
dans les 100 prochaines années
vous